so I just discovered
the easiest way to save your ggplot
figures in r in just one line of code
[Music]
so you've created this amazing figure in
r
but what's next you want to bring that
figure into your report or publication
right but how do you do that so you
could click around rstudio and try to
find a way to save it that way but
there's no way to be consistent you see
like maybe a a week or a few weeks or a
month later you might come back to it
wanting to save that same figure again
perhaps you want to make a modification
to it in the r code and you want to save
the figure but you find that the figure
saves at a slightly different size or or
a different aspect ratio and something
doesn't quite look right compared to the
original figure
so that's why it's always important to
have uh to save your figures directly in
the code of your script so stick around
to learn a game-changing way to save
your figures in r
before I start I just wanted to let you
know that my course on the basics of our
free ecology is now open for enrollment
uh also have my introduction to data
visualization and R for Ecology that's
also available for enrollment right now
I'm super super excited and stoked about
these courses it's it's literally what I
wish I had as a grad student going into
ecology and I've really kind of tailored
everything down to really only the
essential tools the essential functions
that you need to know to become really
proficient in using our for your
ecological data quickly and effectively
without that crazy learning curve that
everyone talks about with r so if you're
interested check out the link below I
think there's going to be a link in this
video up here somewhere in this video
and down below if you are interested in
enrolling and without further Ado let's
jump into this tutorial
all right so for this tutorial we're
going to be using ggplot2 if you don't
have it installed already you want to
run install.packages
ggplot2
but I already have it installed so I'm
not going to be running that I'll just
comment that out and I will run Library
so after you have it installed Run
library ggplot
2. run that it ran successfully
okay so let's pull in the loblolly pine
data set so we'll use the data function
to pull in this data we'll call it's
called Loblolly with a capital l lob La
Li and this is a type of pine tree
and let's take a look at this data set
so whenever you run the data function
you get this thing called promise and
then whenever you use that data it it'll
appear as an actual
data set here or you can just click here
and it'll just appear
let's take a look at it by running the
help function and you can search Lobby
look I had already done that and here it
is the Loblolly data frame has 84 rows
and three columns of records of growth
of loblolly pine trees so
one column is height which so when
running this
just run this on its own
these are the three columns of 84 rows
so one column is height a numeric Vector
of tree Heights in feet then we have age
the numeric factor of Three Ages in
years and Seed an ordered Factor
indicating the seed source for the tree
the ordering is according to increase in
maximum height okay so we don't have to
worry about the ordering because we'll
we might not even use seed but basically
seed is the the seed source for each of
these seedlings
now let's create a really simple ggplot
figure
we'll actually let's rename this just so
that
Pine data a little more explanatory than
just Loblolly
okay and then let's do Gigi plot
Pine data
we'll add some Aesthetics here by saying
y equals height
and x equals age so we're just going to
plot height and age we're not going to
worry about seed here
and we'll add a we'll make this a
scatter plot so we'll use geom point
and all the information should be there
let's see what happens when we run this
okay there we have it we have age on the
x-axis height on the y-axis and here we
have
you see age was only measured at certain
intervals so kind of soon after the
start then every five years after that
which is why we have all these points
clustered all together like that but
let's just say this is the plot that we
want to save so here is the magic sauce
the one line of code that can save this
plot for you
it's just GG save
and now let's name the plot
let's say my Pine plot and let's save it
as a PDF so all we have to do is do dot
PDF and the cooling route you save is it
knows and picks up on the fact that we
said dot PDF and knows to save it as a
PDF there is an argument where we can
specify that specifically but the cool
thing about it is it just knows
automatically so look at that this is
not just one line of code it's a very
short line of code and we run that
and we get this little message saving
6.36 by 5.24 in image now let's take a
look at that I'm going to pull it up
here
from so keep in mind that when you run
this it'll save in the current working
directory and if you use projects like I
recommend everyone does then it will be
in the so here I have this YouTube R
tutorials project where I save all of
this stuff if we go to the root
directory here of this project file
you'll see the dot rproj our project
file and that is the base directory so
we can see here we save this as my Pine
plot it will have saved in the base
directory and here it is my Pine plot
let's we can actually open it right from
here
it'll open in a separate window which I
will drag in front here
but that is it right there
now this isn't
the best looking figure and one big
value in Saving figures directly in your
code is that you can specify the exact
dimensions that you want so let's try
this again but this time let's specify
the dimensions and all we have to do to
do that is simply go
width equals let's make it four by four
four height
equals four and we also have to set the
new the units Now the default units are
inches so we'll we can leave it at that
and it should look the same but so
there's no future confusion uh or or mix
up if if the default changes or if
you're not sure what the units are let's
just declare them here so it's all
explicit units equals
i n for inch and let's save it one more
time this time actually let's rename it
say four by four
great and now let's pull this new plot
up it should be in here look my Pine
plot 4x4
nice okay so now it's got a nice aspect
ratio we can actually compare it with
the other one just to show you that the
size is different
yeah look it's kind of coming off the
screen I can make them both smaller
yeah so you can see the text size stayed
the same it's just the plot got bigger
so then the proportions kind of go off
so you can play around with and I've got
some blog posts and videos on how to
play around with prototyping your plots
until they look really nice so I'm not
going to go into that here but the point
is that you can keep playing around with
it
and that's it for a really simple and
easy and quick way to be able to
directly save your figures with just one
line of code right in R if you want to
see the next part of this video where I
take that figure to the next level
making it look much nicer by editing its
ggplot theme and adding a few additions
then be sure to subscribe so that you
can see when this next video comes out
if you like this video be sure to click
the like button comment down below if
you have any questions or if you want to
share any cool figures that you've been
working on I'm always excited to read
everything down below and the more
excitement and the more enthusiasm I get
from everyone the more likely I'm going
to be posting more and more videos so
yeah thanks again for watching really
really appreciate it and stay tuned for
the next part of this video where I take
this plot to the next level
foreign
[Music]